his film districts logo based on the
scene and Attack of the Clones when
Anakin and obi-wan were being chased
through Corsa look at our strong viewer
all president who punches like a man was
out there advises travel are you kidding
me
in what world is the weather they've
shown drivable they would actually risk
the president's life in this kind of
storm and this is all for some
reelection appearance but sit by the
fire watch Breaking Bad
fine by me Forbes is gonna lose it when
he sees general Clegg helping Walter
White hide from the DEA the Camp David
entrance sign is not over the road but
it's on the side of the road did they
not have Google in 2013 how long does it
take to get to the peoc four minutes
security cameras how many of audio only
the ones in the common areas not bad
it's got it huh what exactly does he
have the ability to remember four things
we're gonna make a Secret Service agent
out of you yet first they needed to
school the kid in the finer points of
drug use and hiring prostitutes which is
what the Secret Service is basically
known for nowadays the first lady
doesn't have enough sense to wear a coat
or any warm clothes during a blizzard
likely upon did you find this just half
my ways
the first lady is a grave robber how are
these guys able to run on this bridge
that I believe is made of ice based on
how brittle the barrier seemed to be it
would seem like the soles of their shoes
have better traction than the tires on
the president's motorcade no wow this is
making me seasick for no reason I bet
they started filming the director said
of the cameraman no no the other way
let's cut and do it again and the camera
guy responded no I got this the TV in
their kitchen is conveniently showing
something that pertains to the events
that later occur in the movie we should
take that holiday that we've been
talking about
I wonder if this man will encounter a
very intense crisis before he ever gets
to take that vacation with his beautiful
wife action movies featuring presidents
are always very very careful not to
indicate their political parties some
people do take holidays you know in case
you missed the part where his wife bakes
him to go on vacation here's another bit
of dialogue to let you know he's a
workaholic also this is twice now
they've said holidays they mean
vacations right I'm sorry I thought this
was America house
president son misses his mom and we
didn't do a good enough job telling you
the president's son's name is Connor or
else that awkward response would exist
hey James Thanks
stopping someone just before they leave
pausing for an almost uncomfortable
amount of time and saying thanks cliche
wait is complicated but isn't this photo
from the night she died
that's dark ma'am I'll take care of her
no he's flashing back to the tragedy
that happened 10 minutes ago and of
course the hero's wife works at a
hospital those are some crudely
photoshopped photos of the president's
family I'm pretty sure president Asher
faked his family vacations like
President Nixon faked the moon landing I
hate Camp David we really have to go
this is where his mother died no he does
not have to go why even bring it up I
got three minutes let's run down to the
kitchen get some ice cream three minutes
to get ice cream even if they couldn't
get to the kitchen in enough time to eat
the ice cream they would get a colossal
brain freeze if there was any hope they
could make it back in time they had to
put this text in the corner because
there was no way for them to integrate
him being the vice president into the
dialogue you might be thinking to
yourself
couldn't president Asher say something
like what do you think mr. vice
president but surprisingly no he can't
totally absolutely did they manage to
get a Lockheed ac-130 into the US
without raising any eyebrows the only
way this is even remotely feasible is if
it folds up into a George Jetson style
briefcase even then you couldn't get
that thing through the TSA they lock you
in a special room if you have too much
shampoo they probably shoot you on the
spot if you had a heavily-armed
long-endurance ground-attack military
plane in a briefcase
please join us that's not protocol sir
he's coming with us but the president
really let a foreign minister in his
entourage into the most super secret
bowels of the underground bunker one of
these high-level security experts should
tell him no two times instead of just
once
also Kang's plan will only work if the
president is being super nice slash a
super idiot and letting them into the
bunker with him South Korean Prime
Minister might be able to go with him
but his aide sure as hell wouldn't I
appreciate the sentiment
but this isn't Grand Theft Auto you
can't shoot an ac-130 down with a
handgun I'd also like to mention that
this giant ass plane that is shooting
everyone in DC was able to make it past
a Marine Air Base to naval bases five
Air National Guard bases and five Air
Force bases with only one minor hiccup
luckily we have some Secret Service
agents The Washington DC Police
Department add a Scottish actor to
defend the nation's capital now I'm no
military expert but even I find it hard
to believe that DC doesn't have some
secret laser missile that can read
thoughts Orson that would be able to
take down this plane Oh also where is
the Air Force right now also what I
think just happened is the Korean plane
just deflected those secret building
bombs with a sparkler shield Lord we're
to a dislocation labeling why are they
there has to be some idiots peeking in
their earpieces saying hold your fire
and they are all committed to their
commander
I guess the White House anti-aircraft
guns gave up after that one attempt
failed I'm starting to think that all
the branches in the military are
secretly working for the Koreans
otherwise there is no logical
explanation why any branch of the
military hasn't arrived yet
I see they sent the entire might of one
u.s. plane to shoot down this Korean
fighter traffic moves along normally
during the worst attack the White House
has never seen ok this is falling ok
wait now it's fault ok for real now it's
falling but slowly because the area
where the Washington Monument resides
has a slightly reduced gravitational
pull how in the mother are people still
near this thing wouldn't they run for
their lives when a giant-ass plane hit
it earlier all the DC residents in this
movie have terrible timing when it comes
to running away from things coordinating
care force FAA find out if this one
aircraft based on the way this has gone
so far I don't think either one of those
organizations are gonna know diddly
Bruce why was my son Ruth there is the
Secretary of Defense
she is not babysitter and cheap dude I'm
sorry president dude it is beyond
implausible any civilians would be in
front of the White House right now a
side effect of being in the proximity of
a bomb is bouncing away as if you're on
a trampoline
the North Korean insurgents have access
to RPGs and other high-powered weaponry
and the Secret Service seems to only
have access to cork pop pistols and guns
that shoot little Flags sake bang on
them why is it that even with the
hundreds of Secret Service agents
fighting banning is the only one who has
the wherewithal to hide behind something
there's already been hundreds of
civilian casualties but a dog come on we
already know they're evil further
evidence that in this version of America
there is only one guy in the Secret
Service who can actually shoot well look
who finally decided to show up no no
it's fine just mosey on in whenever you
feel like it slow down I can't tell who
was betraying whom here now that was a
real gamble shooting at the guy who was
right in front of the president it's
good he was kind of chubby or Ken could
have eliminated his most valuable
bargaining chip now come on what is it
with these Korean terrorists ability to
obtain large modes of transportation
without any problems clearly all normal
military protocols are being damned here
and the normal process of the theft of a
commercial vehicle like a dump truck
being immediately reported to police and
probably the military is completely
ignored also these trucks wouldn't be
able to get this close to the White
House all these areas have been heavily
blocked off for years by objects that an
RPG wouldn't be able to flatten enough
for a dump truck to drive over also I
feel like all the research I'm doing for
this has put me on some terror watch
lists with the NSA that's great guys
thirty-five miles an hour is perfect
enjoy this nice day before saving
America it looks like these guys in
suits with guns are just running out
single file with no cover and shooting
aimlessly what's next as a group of 13
year olds with super soakers going to
take on the terrorists
starting to think that on the other side
of that door is the imaginary boyfriend
machine from inside out it's not even
funny now why are they in front of the
door started to feel like Sweeney Todd
they all deserve to die so far all this
has been accomplished by only like 100
terrorists but also 100 terrorists how
do they all come in via China on fake
passports and the weapon resourcing and
the meticulous planning this is insanely
expensive North Korea isn't actually
funding this than who the hell is oh my
god it's the same guy it was before
did no one teach them you have to pull
the trigger for the gun to shoot not
like the alien gun for district 9
thinking won't make it do anything this
is fine roll Krampus is fine roll crud
be strong all right
roll credits this is the most cinematic
TV news has ever looked also the
military has done a basically
non-existent job so far so I guess it
makes sense that this reporter is able
to be this close to what is now a war
zone the White House the most protected
building on earth I'd like to see the
source on that this is actually one of
the most subtle moments of the movie so
far completely forgot about this kid he
is having a rough couple of years this
isn't the last time he types in a code
like this you would think that the
military would change these codes every
few months but then you would be
breaking the cardinal rule for watching
this movie thinking I understand that
she's a person with a loved one in an
emergency but I just been a terrorist
victim clinging to life I would flip my
bus on nurse on the phone in the hallway
I really don't think nurses would do
that he sold this country out long
before I ever did globalization and Wall
Street what's it cost to buy a
presidency nowadays anyway his
complaints about the president sound
more like a sophomore from Vassar who is
heavily invested in the Occupy movement
when a former Secret Service agent
committing treason gray charged on human
Conner yeah why the hell with the bad
guy even mentioned the president's kid's
name what does that even matter don't we
have a picture that's the second time
some asshole has said this explicitly in
the movie for no reason all right over
zealous location Leibler we know that
it's the Oval Office that's the only
oval-shaped office in the world the
combination of this safe is the exact
same as it was before Mike got fired for
letting the president's wife dot once
again Lincoln's head figures prominently
in someone's death we can't just recall
the seventh Fleet Rumble Freeman is
right we can't just do that it's a
pretty embalmed operation that would
probably take a few months also the
seventh Fleet is not just out patrolling
the Korean Peninsula all the time they
spend most of their time at the base on
Yokosuka which is near Tokyo you know
what I think you get it this is a
ridiculous request can gets the
president to order this guy to give his
coat away but I don't understand why it
doesn't just threaten everyone's life
for the remaining two codes as well
since he needs all three sure they're
trying some hack behind the scenes but
why not expedite the process these codes
are only seven digits
my electric company requires a minimum
of eight with a symbol no wonder Olympus
has fallen
no job a US military Admiral would never
get a terrorist to code with this much
importance even if the president
commanded him to also how did this evil
plan luck out and managed to get all
three people who know these codes in the
same room good well trained and well
organized
it sounds like an extremely die hard
situation well whoever they are good or
maybe you guys are bad that's gonna be
fine
uncapable promises what is he counting
for he has no idea when they're gonna
start shooting let's get here the future
how are none of these bullets hitting
them and he just blindly shot a guy
through a wall nobody Jimmi Klim I
taught you nose guard mwah oh come on
you did not have the time to teach the
president's kid anything about chimney
climb you also in case you were
wondering the president's kid's name is
Connor why would he tell Connor to wait
wouldn't it be better if he just got out
of there instead of waiting for banning
to fight these guys what if he gets
killed yes the movie would be over which
would be sweet relief to everyone but
they could just poke their head in that
vent that seems to have no real purpose
and see the kid trying to escape
yeah banning has a knife and a gun but
this is better it's almost like this
movie really wanted Morgan Freeman to be
the president but that would have
involved putting him in the hospital and
he wouldn't been able to make this
speech and that was unacceptable
so they made him the house speaker so
that he could be acting president
because let's face it Morgan Freeman is
the Acting President I am still being
forced to believe that one guy is slowly
taking out a terrorist organization that
basically killed the entire Secret
Service they had a throne at least one
Jack Bauer style torture scene Sarah
this is one of the most wanted
terrorists in the world
the government has facial recognition
software that could easily identify this
bad guy that was in the South Korean
entourage but apparently didn't find it
useful enough during the vetting process
nobody ever thought to look for him
inside the South Korean government
that's because he had those glasses on
at first it's the perfect disguise
terrorists don't wear glasses one would
assume that the walls in the president's
super secret bunker would be a little
harder to penetrate
shrinkin that's what all this theater
banging seems to trust him he could just
shoot him in the head and that would be
the end of it but I understand we have
to work in another fight see Jesus
we knew this movie was basically die
hard at the White House but the scene is
almost note-for-note the hans gruber
plays like he's a good guy scene all the
way down to smoking a cigarette
well that escalated slowly a switchblade
does this make the North Koreans the
Sharks of the Jets also flicking the
cigarette was a great way to get the
fight started fair because it took away
any element of surprise on Forbes is n
us but wait oh come on they're really
pulling a Darth Vader Anakin Skywalker
with Forbes the difference here is
Forbes has absolutely no real motivation
for any of his actions throughout this
whole movie house man
a person who was just beaten so savagely
should be asking how's my face and teeth
and kidneys but since she's a lady at
all how the hell would they get that
doesn't matter we'll take it out first
of all it does matter
second of all jacobs keeps asking pretty
valid questions and get the answers
kelly install the american hydro
technology for this White House takeover
but it's absolutely amazing something
like this wasn't on the White House
protecting it before the attack I want
to lis name this movie if the military
was a colossal joke what is happening on
the screen right now Galaga abort abort
now why don't we just wait until
everyone's dead to abort Mike surmise
this why don't they just drop a bomb on
the White House let Morgan Freeman be
president and count that as a win fi am
ordering you to stand down
Clegg thinks it's okay they're just
completely violate chain of command in
front of an Acting President if I didn't
absolutely need you I would believe you
right now does he absolutely need him
he's been pretty useless so far I will
not let this animal out of here Merrick
Ruby generals are always about two
deaths away from a coup in declaring
themselves in charge recalling the
seventh fleet which we discussed earlier
is impossible that is not the angle in
which Mike is being broadcast okay two
sins for this one for this just being
absolutely ridiculous and two for the
Pledge of Allegiance just generally
being a strange thing why are we pledge
allegiance to the flag and why are we
doing it really strange times like when
we're being dragged to your execution or
before first period how are these news
cameras able to get close enough to
capture this footage and why are the
people in the Pentagon watching it on
the news
someone really needs to teach these
people how to military it's just sad now
this asshole takes forever to shoot
McMillan and he knows mike is wandering
around somewhere Manning still has
excellent aim even when he's not looking
fire hey he was able to hear Trumbull
even though he didn't have the earpiece
it
response to the attack on the White
House is jubilant too dangerous to pick
one particular country so just the
generalized Middle East will do this guy
driving that tank is really taking the
order to withdraw to a cartoonish level
I'm impressed that they were able to
make it out of the White House and onto
the North Lawn without anyone tripping
I'm sorry to report the president was on
that helicopter how do you know because
you saw it on the news it doesn't make
sense which part the renegade North
Korean terrorist who took down the
presidency with one plane a hundred
people a couple vans bombs and guns or
all the rest of it I'd say both can we
not go out like that sir it's not who
yet the hero has insight into the
villain he's never met Cleef it no
country will be a cold dog nuclear
wasteland correction the world will be a
cold dark nuclear wasteland setting off
basically all the nuclear warheads in
the US which is the overwhelming
majority of nuclear warheads would be a
huge loss for anyone planning to live on
earth somewhere in some government IT
room a person got to design a nuclear
countdown clock and that's the font he
went with time the goal mr. president I
leave that bunker is probably the safest
place to be when all those nukes go off
this asshole picks the perfect time to
get in the elevator and make it down
here right when Kang is leaving this
movie has more bullet wounds than I can
count
but it is also one of the stabby astac
ssin films ever James Bond has
conditioned me to want to root for the
handsome guy in nice clothes so this is
a very confusing fight not sure how he's
gonna school stabbed his way out of this
one maybe he should think of codes as
knives and an active nuclear countdown
as a skull buying a control panel marked
counter man then go to preferences and
select default media browser so the
deactivation code is in the Pentagon but
the only computer that can turn off all
the nuclear bombs is in the bunker
that seems smart after Mike told
everybody Kang was dead and the
president was hurt how are there not
tons of military and medical personnel
rushing through the White House right
now also not only does the president
survive this but he is able to sort of
walk out of the building even with the
bullet wound in his gut and the
significant loss of blood
you
it's first purchased by a
great-grandfather during the First World
War
work work work work work work work work
work hello boys have a good night's rest
I missed you we're gonna roll it baby
rolling ready here we go
no no no why are you coming to me your
job right Oh Mary get me some coffee
well thank me up a cup of coffee and
chocolate donut with some of those
little sprinkles on top well you're
going are you thinking mr. mcclain mr.
Officer John McClane of the New York
Police Department if I didn't absolutely
need you I would believe you right now I
will not let this arrow I don't all turn
on you can't fight it here this is the
war room the night is darkest just
before the dawn
I promise you the dawn is coming
one day the Batman will have to answer
for the laws he's broken but to us not
to this madman